et pour revenir sur la réforme des
retraites dans un contexte politique
mouvant gilles casanova consultant en
stratégie et communication nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau gilles casanova
bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
alors on l'a vu une nouvelle
mobilisation aujourd'hui à paris un
contre la réforme des retraites à
proximité du palais bourbon
d'après vous c'est davantage symbolique
où les gens aujourd'hui sont encore
déterminé pense encore pouvoir activer
le retrait du projet de la réforme des
retraites si on prend un peu de distance
on voit que l'âge moyen de la vie tourne
entre 80 et 85 ans donc on est un homme
une femme
selon qu'on est cadre supérieur ou
ouvriers et que la retraite se situe
entre 60 et 67 ans selon la réforme qui
aura ou pas lieu ça nous fait une
vingtaine d'années pendant lesquelles on
n'a plus la capacité par soi même de
trouver des ressources et donc on dépend
de la retraite organisée par les
systèmes sociaux donc comprenez bien que
les gens ont le sentiment qu'il joue
vingt années de leur vie et les vingt
années leur vie pendant lesquelles ils
pensent qu'ils vont pouvoir se reposer
après avoir longtemps travaillé
est-ce que vous pensez que quinze jours
un mois six semaines trois mois cela
suffit à éteindre cette inquiétude
non cela ne l'atteint pas si les
manifestations sont moins nombreuses
ici ou là si elles sont demain plus
nombreuses
ici ou là ça n'est un indice que de
circonstance sur le fond le président
macron en s'attaquant à cette réforme
s'attaque un pilier central de la france
la retraite c'est la richesse de ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas d'autres
alors détermination des opposants vous
venez de le rappeler détermination
également du chef de l'état je le cite
il faut gagner la bataille des retraites
at il dit la semaine dernière appelant
les députés de la majorité à vendre
cette réforme de justice comment est ce
que vous comprenez cette détermination
totale du chef de l'état il n'a jamais
été élu il n'a jamais été candidat à
autre chose que la très médiatique
élection présidentielle il n'a donc
jamais été ouverte
il n'a jamais été confronté au
gouvernement des hommes il a toujours
été confronté à la gouvernance des
choses en tant que technocrates et il
pense que la gouvernance des choses
l'emportera mais dans la réalité ça
n'est jamais arrivé
c'est le gouvernement des hommes qui
peut l'emporter et on voit que sa
méthode de gouvernance des choses
réussies un élément de sa promesse c'est
en même temps il réussit à avoir en même
temps l'ensemble des crises que les
présidents de la vème république ont eu
eux chacun une à une et il réunit en
même temps en ce moment autour de lui
l'ensemble de ces crises pourquoi parce
que la gouvernance des choses ne permet
pas le gouverner une nation et que ses
prédécesseurs
s'il avait toujours préféré la
gouvernance des choses au gouvernement
des hommes connaissaient cependant un
peu le gouvernement d homme sinon il ne
serait pas arrivé là où il était arrivé
du coup quand certains disent qu'ils
pourraient utiliser le 49-3 pour faire
passer cette réforme des retraites pour
vous c'est quelque chose de plausible
ceci étant quelles conséquences ça pour
avoir déjà cette réforme apparaît mal
ficelé le conseil d'état a dit
son insécurité juridique si elle était
votée par le 49-3 dans cette insécurité
juridique
ce serait l'assurance que le conseil
constitutionnel lui ferait un sort peu
enviable
on peut imaginer en revanche que
l'exécutif se tourner vers les
ordonnances le vote d'une loi
d'habilitation à gouverner par
ordonnance pourrait s'étendre sur
plusieurs mois pendant lesquels
pourraient être enfin écrit de cette
réforme qui pour l'instant n'est qu'un
brouillard ou alors un débat qui avait
qui a débuté à l'assemblée nationale
dans un contexte particulier on lisait
le départ d'agnès busin l'arrivée
d'olivier vers ans comme ministre de la
santé est ce que c'est une bonne
stratégie du gouvernement sont selon
vous en ce qui concerne ce dossier
majeur qui est celui de la réforme des
retraites est bien une fois de plus on
enlève un des responsables du suivi de
cette réforme de sa place pour le placer
ailleurs pour des raisons terriblement
politicienne on peut penser que cela ne
fera qu'aggraver cette avalanche de
crise qui s'entraînent les unes les
autres autour de l'exécutif
vous avez vu par exemple qu'il ya
quelques jours dans le créneau qui était
laissé à république et territoires
le groupe parlementaire de la majorité
n'a pas réussi à faire voter contre une
proposition de loi de ce groupe
ça veut dire que à chaque étape le
système se grippe
on voit bien que le en même temps est en
train de devenir un tous ensemble c'est
à dire que tous ces problèmes
s'additionnent et risquent de se
multiplier
ça n'est pas un très bon présage pour un
projet aussi énorme que celui de changer
les retraites dans ce pays
merci beaucoup gilles casanova d'avoir
partagé oui réalise sur notre plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes consultant en
stratégie et en communication